[Music]
on this friday night china fires back we
could expect some retaliation beijing's
escalating rhetoric after ottawa banned
chinese tech giant huawei plus the
implications for canadian consumers
canadians will continue to pay some of
the highest streets in the world
still in power with no replacement in
sight jason kenney remains in his post
as alberta's premiere for now where does
his divided party go from here
confirmed cases with monkey pox now
verified in canada the search is on for
a source what we need to do is to
identify all of the cases really
understand the scope of what we're
dealing with plus prisoners of war the
uncertain fate of hundreds of ukrainian
fighters my husband is on the way from
one health to another hell and the
russian musician being jailed for his
show of support
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thank you for joining
us the political fallout taking shape
after canada made the move to ban
chinese tech giant huawei from 5g
networks in the name of national
security
the decision critics say took far too
long and leaves canada in a vulnerable
position as telecom companies have two
years to remove huawei's 5g equipment
it took three years to announce a ban
and huawei is still operating in canada
the government wasted precious time and
now they ask us to wait even longer for
legislation that will finally protect
canadians and close this embarrassing
chapter for our country
well tonight many are holding their
breath for possible retaliation from
china that could see increased risk and
tension for canadian travel and trade
our abigail beeman leads our coverage
tonight from ottawa
beijing is planning a quote
comprehensive and serious assessment of
canada's decision to ban huawei which
china claims violates free trade the
embassy in ottawa said canada's
so-called security concerns are just a
pretext for political manipulation we
could expect some retaliation it'll be
annoyed that it came just a day after
the
they had lifted the ban on the two
canola firms but i'm not sure that it
will delay
or reverse chinese efforts to rebuild a
relationship china watchers are divided
on both if and how the country may
choose to strike back any retaliation by
the chinese regime will only worsen
relations it's it's to no one's benefit
whatsoever charles burton says china
could do lots of things block exports
kick out canadian journalists cyber
spying or more arrests many thinking of
canadian robert shellenberg detained
since 2014 and facing a death sentence i
think the the level of risk for
canadians in china whether they're
businessmen or
english teachers or or students you know
has
been enhanced
the prime minister signaled canada is
braced for retaliation particularly on
trade we understand that it may well
lead to challenges of the world trade
organization
but we feel that it is extremely
important to stand up for canadian
protection canadian interests and
canadian safety though some question how
safe things really are both in terms of
how much longer it took canada to make
this decision than allies and because
there's still time before companies need
to remove huawei gear in the meantime
for four years
canada is going to be exposed to exactly
the national security risk that we've
been concerned about all along global
affairs canada currently recommends
using a high degree of caution if
traveling to china we asked if there are
any plans to change the advisory and
we're told they monitor safety and
security 24 7. abigail beeman global
news ottawa
so what does this mean for canadians and
data as ann gaviolan tells us the
already slow implementation of 5g in
this country could be about to see even
more delays
after years of policy limbo it should be
full steam ahead for canada's much
anticipated 5g rollout the new
generation of wireless technology that
will allow for truly unlimited data
plans and things like smart homes and
cars
four canadian telecoms including the big
three bell telus and rogers have started
deploying 5g but it's not the full nine
yards think of it as four and a half g
experts say canada has lots of catching
up to do canada is a lot further away
from that 5g rollout compared to other
countries like the us like south korea
this has been a long time coming the u.s
banned huawei three years ago canada's
delay comes at a price samara bushey is
the man behind ice wireless which
provides wireless service to thousands
of customers in remote northern
communities that is their lifeline
that's their connection to the world his
company which specializes in the
technology that makes zoom and skype
calls possible relies heavily on huawei
components and has invested tens of
millions because they're cheap and very
reliable in cold climates he says this
announcement puts small players that
serve remote and rural communities at a
disadvantage against the deep pocketed
big three who opted for more expensive
alternatives
the ugly part here is canadians will
continue so to pay some of the highest
rates in the world
because
the
incumbents will continue to have the
upper hand if the government had made a
decision sooner than those smaller
players could have figured out a
different alternative route to what they
could have done instead of already
placing out all of that infrastructure
in those northern communities a national
security ban that impacts household
budgets across the country ann gaviola
global news toronto
the united conservatives in alberta are
divided but jason kenny is reversing
course since announcing his resignation
wednesday night and will remain the
premier of alberta and the leader of the
party until a new leader is chosen
now that was decided after a day-long
caucus meeting yesterday in calgary and
that is where we find global's tom
vernon who's been following the events
up to this week including a ucp cabinet
meeting today
tom how does kenny plan to continue to
lead the party after what's happened
tracy he says after that long caucus
meeting yesterday and him remaining on
as premier until a new leader is elected
is a sign of a government that continues
to do the people's business as it works
to find a new leader now he entered this
cabinet meeting to a standing ovation
from his cabinet ministers this was a
photo opportunity for the meeting he sat
down and in his comments he spoke about
ucp government priorities fighting bill
c-69 in court building the economy and
dealing with inflation now it was a
marathon caucus meeting that led to him
remaining in power he obviously had
enough votes in caucus to keep hold of
the top job now we spoke with one of the
constituency association presidents one
of the grassroots members that has
worked so hard to remove jason kenney
and he says well look this is what they
expected but they have accomplished
their mission
after my initial feelings of
perhaps disappointment some shock maybe
even a little bit of anger uh
we were still able to accomplish what
the number one objective was and that
was to see jason kenny no longer the
leader of our party
now what's very interesting is we
haven't heard from any of his opponents
just yet people like brian jean who
going into yesterday's caucus meeting
made their thoughts pretty clear they
were going in to remove him as leader
and elect an interim leader in fact the
only comment we've heard was actually
from brian jean's camp and they said in
the statement brian is going to let
albertans and the grassroots digest the
unusual events of the last two days
before he comments
always interesting times here tracy
we'll have to see where this story takes
us next tom vernon in calgary thank you
so much
you bet
canadian health care officials continue
to look for cases of monkey pox after
two people in quebec tested positive for
the virus now the story we're about to
show you includes footage of people with
the disease
jamie morocco has more on how monkey pox
is spreading around the world and how we
can protect each other
scientists at winnipeg's national
microbiology lab have been tasked with
testing monkey pox samples taken from
quebec patients we understand from other
countries reporting cases
that the current monkey parks strain or
clade if you like is the west african
clade
we have not
yet
confirmed that in canada
it would be unusual none of the
confirmed cases or more than 20
potential cases under investigation in
quebec have recently traveled to africa
where monkey pox is seen annually dr
anne ramoyne has spent two decades
studying the disease in the region and
says finding the origin of spread is now
key
right now we just don't have those
answers so it's really important to
to go back to the beginning and remember
that
we're in very early days what we need to
do is to identify all of the cases
really understand the scope of what
we're dealing with and then look to see
what kind of common denominator there is
clusters of the virus have been reported
in britain spain and portugal with more
cases popping up in the u.s australia
and across europe dr robert polarsky
works at a sexual health clinic in
montreal and treated some of the
suspected patients should we vaccinate
everybody i do not think should we
vaccinate people who are at high risk i
believe i believe it would be very wise
idea public health officials are
considering a ring strategy that would
include using a smallpox vaccine for
close contacts of those infected doses
have proven effective against monkey pox
and are already being offered in britain
smallpox was eradicated in 1980 in terms
of you know vaccination campaigns i
think in canada that stopped in the
early 70s and so i would say generally
the entire population is susceptible to
this
to monkey pox officials wouldn't say how
many smallpox vaccines are available for
those seeking personal protective
options you might feel a sense of deja
vu
experts recommend masking hand washing
and physical distancing when needed
mitigation measures with which we've
become all too familiar jamie morocco
global news toronto
canada has imposed sanctions on 14 more
russians associated with vladimir
putin's regime ottawa is also banning
the export and import of some luxury
goods to and from russia including
alcohol clothing and jewelry
it comes as a ukrainian commander says
troops have ended their defense of
mariupol's as of stealth steel works
effectively giving russia full control
of ukraine's southeastern coastal area
redmond shannon reports
according to the kremlin this is the
last group of exhausted and deflated
ukrainian troops walking out of the azov
style steelworks after more than 80 days
inside the bombarded facility russia now
claims all 2400 ukrainian troops inside
have surrendered
earlier friday the leader of the azov
battalion admitted the fight for as of
style was over russia says he was taken
away in an armored car they say to
prevent locals from attacking him
russia's invasion was predicated on the
far right routes of the azov battalion
so his capture would be a key propaganda
victory for the kremlin
in turkey the wives of some of the other
ukrainian soldiers appealed for help
fearing what will happen to them my
husband
is
on the way from one hell to another hell
from other steel plant to as a prison
change the hearts and converts the
hearts that horrors like this the
vatican's foreign secretary visited the
site of mass graves north of key friday
responding to calls for pope francis to
travel to ukraine or to help with peace
talks he knows that there is
a desire for a visit and he is more than
willing to assist either himself
personally or through his
immediate collaborators bombing
continues across the east including at
this cultural center in harkee region
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says the eastern donbass region is now
completely destroyed
russia's defense minister claims his
forces will soon have control over the
entire luhans part of the donbass
russian natural gas giant gazprom
announced friday it will now suspend all
sales to finland for failing to pay its
bills in rubles just days after finland
and sweden formally applied to join nato
redmond shannon double news london
a pianist who played the ukrainian
national anthem in public has been found
guilty of nazi propaganda by a russian
court
a video posted to social media shows
vladimir puffenov playing the piano in
the siberian city of tioman the city's
court says that amounts to shouting
slogans of banned organizations
now the video does not show fufenov
shouting or speaking any slogans he has
been sentenced to 14 days in jail
coming up tracing a serial number the
calls for ramped up gun tracing from
canada's law enforcement
[Music]
a lot can be learned about the history
and life of an illegal gun by tracing
its serial number where it was
manufactured and sold and who bought it
it's an important tool when a gun is
found at a crime scene to help identify
traffickers now global news has learned
only about 10 to 20 percent of crime
guns are being traced in canada tonight
we bring you part three of our
investigative series following the path
of one gun
we went looking for jermaine welsh he's
a canadian who was living in michigan in
2014 when he and several others were
arrested after purchasing more than a
hundred guns that were smuggled into
canada he used to live here two and a
half years ago global news has learned
welsh's brother and co-conspirator
steven durant was sentenced to 60 months
in prison for his part in the scheme
welsh received a sentence of 36 months
probation in texas for one count of
false statement during acquisition of a
firearm or as the atf calls it lying and
buying family members tell us they both
eventually moved back to the greater
toronto area the way i know him i don't
think he was bringing to an apartment to
get harmed by it
but they're guns yeah
so i don't think he wants to even
thinking without those guns in canada
jeremy would still be alive
eighteen-year-old jeremy cook and
fourteen-year-old lee sent ross were
killed in separate shootings in ontario
in the summer of 2015
by one of those guns a taurus pt 740
slim
melissa cook wearing a pendant
containing her son's ashes around her
neck
says the people who pulled the trigger
are not the only ones responsible i
think we need to find out where these
guns are coming from you know how
they're getting into our country they
have blood on their hands too why isn't
germaine welsh charged
with buying and giving these guns to
criminals in an unprecedented move in
canada last year toronto police charged
a convicted gun smuggler with criminal
negligence causing death after one of
the guns he smuggled from florida was
allegedly used in a fatal shooting the
case is still before the courts i hope
that it becomes a common theme and that
when you buy a gun at a gun show in
florida it might cross your mind that
geez
if this gets used somewhere i could be
held responsible while an additional
charge of criminal negligence might act
as a deterrent defense lawyers argue it
may not hold up in court
if you then go and charge someone later
on with
negligence causing death and you've
already factored it into their first
sentence
you may be
almost not double dipping but retrying
the same case and there's principles
against charging people for the same
offense twice when somebody is killed
with a firearm where should the
responsibility for that death stop
that's the million dollar question
it was a trace done by the atf that
showed us the path of a single gun from
its point of sale at a gun show in
taylor michigan to the detroit windsor
border later killing a teenager in
london ontario and then another in
toronto it also told us who purchased
the gun to start this deadly chain of
events and without that tracing there's
no way to identify these people
officials say last year more than 30 000
guns were seized in canada
about half are considered crime guns and
ideally every crime gun recovered would
be traced but right now canadian law
enforcement agencies are estimated to be
tracing just over 10 percent ontario
traces
routinely they trace about
2 000 guns a year the rest of the
provinces they we were still working on
them i think if the government was doing
enough
then we wouldn't have the numbers that
we have out there right now we can't
accept it like how many children are
being taken
how many families are being pulled apart
for what reason
you know there's no good reason
buffalo mourns the lives lost in a
racially motivated mass shooting
the first funeral for one of the victims
of last week's deadly supermarket
shooting took place in new york today at
a vigil last night all of the victims
were honored
hundreds of people gathered inside this
buffalo church to mourn those lost in
saturday's mass shooting
ten people
all of whom were black were killed in an
attack authorities are calling a
racially motivated hate crime
more than 17 million australians are
heading to the polls to choose a new
leader
voters are highlighting pandemic
pandemic-fueled inflation the cost of
living and climate change as key issues
for an election choice
scott morrison's conservative coalition
is seeking a fourth three-year term and
he's looking to remain in the top job as
the 30th prime minister of the country
recent polls show the center-left labour
party led by anthony albanese has
narrowed the gap with their main
opposition
next why indigenous leaders remain
optimistic about the road to royal
reconciliation
prince charles and his wife camilla have
wrapped up their whirlwind visit to
canada but their calls for meaningful
action on reconciliation and climate
change remain
we simply must learn practical lessons
from traditional knowledge
through deep connections to land and
water
about how we should treat our planet
the prince says he was deeply moved by
those who spoke about their experiences
in residential schools
as heather eurix west explains
indigenous leaders say the visit has
left them hopeful
it was a spectacle the northern
indigenous community of datta won't soon
forget
just 220 members of the yellowknives
denney first nation call this place home
but with the eyes of the world on them
elder berna martin was ready to share
her thoughts with the community's
distinguished guests
ditching this
woman that go missing murder that's a
big one that's a big one and residential
school that's a big issue too and we
have to deal with it every day the
prince of wales and his wife the duchess
of cornwall spent a busy afternoon with
indigenous leaders in deta and
yellowknife their third stop in a
whirlwind three city canadian tour with
a focus on reconciliation
when prince charles delivered his
farewell address he told the community
he had been touched by their stories it
has been deeply moving to have met
survivors of residential schools
who with such
courage
have shared their experiences
on behalf of my wife and myself i want
to acknowledge their suffering
and to say how much our hearts go out to
them and their families he stopped short
of apologizing on behalf of the crown
though indigenous leaders who met with
the prince earlier this week say they
are hopeful about the road ahead on
twitter the president of the metis
nation of canada said throughout his
visit prince charles has demonstrated
his receptiveness to the many stories
including the profoundly difficult ones
i felt he truly listened during our
conversation and is open to exploring a
shared pathway forward
prince of wales and his wife returned to
the uk late thursday with a promise to
remain in close touch his 19th visit to
canada unlikely to be his last heather
urex west global news yellowknife
and that is global national for this
friday i'm tracy tong tonight's your
canada is kamloops british columbia
thanks so much for watching